Hi, I'm Ido Green.
I'm a Developer Advocate at Google.
>> And I'm Cameron Pittman.
I make front-end courses
here at Udacity.
>> Cameron and I want to help you
a bit with the forms, because almost
any meaningful experience on the webs
come with boxes that need to be filled.
>> It might be a registration form,
a shopping cart or a sign in form.
All of these need simple forms.
And why?
Well, it's because
the simpler the form is,
the more conversions
you're going to see.
>> Right, and in fact,
according to Chrome usage data,
you can make forms 30% faster by
just making them ready to autofill.
We will dive into it
in the second lesson.
For now, just remember that with
faster forms comes happier users and
more conversion.
And that's why we're here.
This course is all about best practices
for designing and developing forms.
We want you to build
forms that work great for
all your users, no matter their
platform, mobile or desktop.
However, mobile platforms are a bit
more of a challenge due to
the smaller screen size.
So we are going to focus on
that more in this course.
>> Yes, and for this course, Ido and
I expect that you're a web developer who
understands the fundamentals of HTML,
CSS, and JavaScript.
We expect that you've been
building sites with forms, and
you're always trying to stay up
to date with best practices.
>> In the first two lessons,
you'll be learning about
inputs that make up forms.
All the little button and
toggles that clutter your user screens.
>> And in the third lesson,
you'll take on forms as a whole and
examine what you can do
to convert more users.
This is especially important for
e-commerce sites, but
it certainly applies to
any kind of long form.
>> In the last lesson, you'll make forms
reactive and touchable for mobile users.
>> That sounds like a lot of fun.
Let's get started.